my favorite skincare ingredient that  you've probably never heard of is  cyclodextrin cyclodextrins are little  rings made out of sugar molecules kind  of like microscopic donuts the really  cool thing about them is that the  outside likes water but the inside likes  oil so that means oily active  ingredients like retinaldehyde can sit  inside the ring and the outside of the  donut helps it dissolve in water on top  of that the ring stabilizes the active  inside by protecting it against other  substances that might come along and  break it down so more of it stays active  until you apply it to your skin there  are lots of retinaldehyde products on  the market now that use cyclodextrin  here are some of them